I know you are pals with the chrisley
family have you spoken to them since all
this has gone down reality TV stars Todd
and Julie Chris Lee are illegal hot
water
we're going to get a second opinion a
married couple along with their
accountant indicted by a federal grand
jury in Atlanta on 12 counts including
tax evasion bank fraud and wire fraud
how are they doing and handling at all I
love Todd and Julie and my heart is
absolutely broken for them they're gonna
get through this they're you know
leaning on the Lord big time I know the
back story so you know they're they're
innocent and all this so I mean the
truth always comes out you know if
they're going through a court case so
right it's it's tough I mean there's not
too much I can say yeah but they're
hanging in there they're hanging in
there it's been definitely hard he's you
know he's asked me you know can you pray
for me and I yeah absolutely and and I
you know I can tell that he's he's
happened having a hard time but and the
flip side he know is that he didn't do
anything wrong so he knows that you know
the truth will come out